denim on the top yes
denim on the bottom
this morning we're making a Canadian
breakfast burrito with the help of
Dempster's original tortillas I'm gonna
take ingredients and flavors from all
over our great nation to make the best
breakfast that any Canuck would be proud
to enjoy
every great breakfast needs scrambled
eggs so here we go a little bit of
melted butter and a low heat
if you like creamy soft scrambled eggs
this is the trick so slowly coagulate
those eggs you're not adding milk you're
not adding cream and you're definitely
not doing this on a high heat
that to me is the perfect scrambled egg
a little bit of salt and no pepper
because our recipe will have spiced
Elements which I'm going to show you I'm
making a spice blend starting with
coriander from Saskatchewan a little bit
of allspice because I'm thinking about
tortiller flavors Montreal hello some
cayenne to give us some heat
and of course some black pepper now
these spices are going to go into our
maple syrup and our ketchup the maple is
going to glaze our pimeo bacon and the
ketchup is just going to be layered
throughout our breakfast burrito
ketchup world's tiniest whisk as always
just to make things more interesting you
know and layer those Canadian influences
aha peimeo bacon this is now the Toronto
representation in our breakfast burrito
when you go to the St Lawrence Market
here in my hometown
P Meal and Kaiser and lots of mustard
that's the way to do it
this is going to cook high and fast and
after I flip it I'm gonna douse it in
that spiced Maple bringing all of our
national flavors together
and now the fun part let's assemble
we've got all these Canadian ingredients
including our dempser's original
tortillas which are made by Canada and
includes Canadian wheat flour almost
time to eat now the order is actually
important I've been strategic about it
start with a little bit of the spice
ketchup right in the middle
now I've got some cheddar from Pei they
make beautiful cheddar in the maritime
shout out to Pi now of course a little
Montreal smoked meat right in the center
some hash browns you're gonna have some
potatoes maritimes have the best
potatoes on Earth then we get those
beautiful scrambled eggs that we made
put them right on top this is a burrito
designed for any Canadian lumberjack
it's tardy
more spiced ketchup on top of the eggs a
little more Pi aged white cheddar
maple glazed pea meal right on top and
now the full two sides in and then from
the bottom over and now we've got a neat
little package
ready for the Press
it's only going to take about three four
minutes till they're golden brown if you
don't have a press you can just toast
them up in a skillet until they're
golden brown and the cheese gets melty
and get creative think about other
Canadian ingredients like cheese curds
uh West Coast salmon
Nanaimo bars ketchup chips whatever you
know
and there you have it my ultimate
Canadian breakfast burrito God I love
this country
[Music]